i wanted to update my video
entitled keto on steroids
so this is the version of the ketogenic diet
that's very very strict and it's for those people
that need to drop weight maybe for a wedding or
a situation or you're at a plateau situation and
you need to jump start your program okay first
thing we're going to talk about is these things
right here they're called carbs normally you
would be given a range between 30 to 50 grams
of carbs per day we're gonna bring that down
to five no more than five carbs per day okay
so best way to do it is through mainly vegetables
now if we take a look at the total carbs and this
is per cup total carb is seven and then
net net carb is three so if you do spinach
all you can do in a given day is do a little more
than one cup right because you want to you want
to keep it within five grams but look at lettuce
right here 0.5 so you could do 10 cups of lettuce
that would be better than spinach avocado you
can do a little more than two cups of avocado
right asparagus look at that point three
so you can do a good amount of asparagus
or olives you can do maybe a little more than
a cup and a half mushrooms you can do several
cups swiss chard you could do quite a bit zucchini
you can do a couple cups arugula you can do more
celery you can do a good amount and then you have
bok choy and then radish and watercress so so
on this program there are things that are very
very important and things that are moderately
important and less important this up here is
very very important to keep these carbs below
5 grams per day not per meal and so really pay
attention to the neck carbs and how many you can
get away with to keep this under 5 grams obviously
like the vegetables right here lettuce asparagus
swiss chard arugula bok choy watercress it's
probably the best right here is better because
you can consume more of it that means you're
going to get vitamin c you're going to get
more nutrients you're going to get more minerals
from that food but it's a lot of fiber as well
so this is number one right here let's talk about
proteins it's very important that you don't overdo
it with protein you don't want to go over seven
or maybe eight ounces for certain individuals
but usually between three to seven ounces okay now
what you're going to be doing is you're going to
be doing omad one meal a day so this is all the
protein that you're going to consume in a given
day if you consume too much protein okay your
body just basically breaks it down and turns into
glucose that's what happens so that can actually
raise insulin so we keep it moderate we're going
to be totally fine the key is having a fattier
type of protein why because that'll keep insulin
lower as well like for example on eggs you don't
want to do just egg whites you want to eat do
the whole egg the yolk as well salmon is the ideal
fish there's a lot of other fatty fish too you can
consume but this is perfect okay summer sausage
has more fat in it just make sure there's no
dextrose in there i just did a video on this i'll
put a link down below hamburger is better than
steak because most steak is fairly on the lean
side there are certain steaks that are fattier
but hamburger is a bit fattier and this is why
i would recommend hamburger over other types of
meats okay eggs duck eggs would be better
than chicken eggs because they're fattier
shellfish would be good pork or lamb
of course from the farmer's market not
from the local 7-eleven and sausage you
want to get the sausage that has the most
fat all right this is your protein now let's get
to the fat of course there's a lot of fat with
this protein right here but the acceptable fats
would be the olive oil extra virgin the real stuff
butter coconut oil lard or tallow now here's the
thing you're gonna put some olive oil on your
salad dressing you can cook with it with butter
you can actually put some on your vegetables
and you can also cook with it coconut oil you
can cook with it lard you can cook with it
tallow you can cook with it but i don't want you
to add a lot more fat to this meal in other words
i don't recommend doing the keto desserts where
you're making these fat bombs not on this program
macadamia nuts and pecans why because they are
the fattiest nut look at the ratio it's like 11.5
fat to one protein so it's 11.5 times greater
in fat than protein amazing pecan is seven times
greater fat than protein now peanuts actually have
the most protein and the lowest fat but that's
a legume the only thing with these two nuts is
you're going to have to look at the carbs because
one ounce is about 1.5 grams of net carb so that
has to be added into this calculation right here
and that will kind of tell you the volume of
how many of these nuts you can have pecans
look at this 1.3 gram net carb per ounce so you
have to add that to your your calculation one more
fat but it's really a combination of fat and
protein but it's actually pretty fatty it's
cod liver not cod liver oil you can buy it in a
can and it's five times as much fat to protein
and you can do this as your fat you're going to
be very very satisfied and plus it has dha big
time it has epa which are which are two omega-3
fatty acids it has vitamin d it has vitamin a it's
going to be extremely satisfying you probably
can consume like a half a can and that will
you'll be very very satisfied okay no dairy too
high in carbs no berries no keto desserts no mct
oil why because your body is going to burn this
more than your own fat and you will be in ketosis
but if your goal is to lose weight just mix this
for right now coffee keep it down to like one
maybe two per day you can do tea through the day
herbal teas totally fine of course don't put sugar
in your coffee electrolytes very very important
because you're going to be doing one meal a day
and you want to make sure you get all of
your nutrients b vitamins nutritional yeast
is a good source a lot if not most of the
b vitamins are water soluble so that means
you don't store them for very long so if you're
not taking them you can end up with a deficiency
vitamin d unless you get sun or you're consuming
the cod liver cod liver oil is a good source
of vitamin d number five sea salt you need
between one to one and a half teaspoons per
day so you're gonna have to either figure out
how to put it on your meal your one meal a day
or even mix it with a little water
slug it down and then drink some water
very important because you're gonna need that to
prevent fatigue and lethargy and even keto flu
so you're gonna do one meal a day and every
two weeks you're gonna do a 48-hour fast this
is called periodic prolonged fasting it's gonna
give your body a huge jump start now exercise
okay twice a week the exercise should be intense
it should be full body ideally to the point where
you're sweating and you're working multiple muscle
groups and that's your high intensity compound
resistant type exercise twice a week spread it
out on the off days you're going to be doing
long walks at least 45 minutes to keep the stress
down ideally exercise during your fasting period
maybe like in the morning if you're going to
eat at night it's not an absolute necessity
but if you can exercise in a fasting state
you can really spike that growth hormone
okay sleep this right here is another one of
those really important things you want to go
to bed a little bit earlier i personally go to
bed at nine o'clock okay i get up really early
but i like to go to bed at nine um it seems to
work occasionally i might even take a little
power nap if you're not sleeping well you
should take some type of sleep aid to assist
yourself i'm talking a natural type of sleep
aid no watching the news you're going to feel
better just from that in fact that might make you
lose weight just by avoiding that cortisol spike
keep your stress as low as possible pick your
friends wisely get some new friends don't hang
around with anyone that is too negative sun would
be very very good if there is sun out that'll be
more vitamin d and also there's other benefits
of being out in the sun as well as being out
in nature very very therapeutic all right there
you have it this is the keto and steroids so some
people need to work up to this some people could
just jump right in it really depends on where
you're at and how motivated you are but this will
definitely take your results to a whole new level
hey before you go real quick i have
a course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today